Lamborghini is bringing back the most famous name in the Italian automaker's history,...
...Countach, and this time it's on an all-new hybrid supercar.
So, it's the interpretation of the Countach of the 21st century.
It's a beautiful car but there's also new technology inside...
...and the super capacitor is a battery...
...which has three times more power than a normal battery and attached to the gearbox.
In terms of layout,...
...you have the engine positioned in the longitudinal in the back of the car...
...so the cabin moved forward.
And for the V12, since the Countach for the first time, we have the scissor doors.
So, it's really a game changer for Lamborghini.
And therefore, even if we don't do normally retro cars,...
...for this car we made an exception.
We have people who are collectors...
...and they finally see also a modern version and they want to have it...
...because it is here a bit last of a kind.
And, on the other hand, we have older grown-up kids...
...which used to have a poster on their wall in the 80s...
...when this car was becoming very famous.